اثار مقطع فيديو الجدل على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي يظهر لحظه اختطاف فتاه من
مجموعه مسلحه في العاصمه الليبيه طرب
طربلوس الحديثه توقعت امام الماره على
الطريق العام في وضح النهر ولم تصدر
السلطات الرسميه اي تفاصيل عن الحادثه
فيما لم يتم الكشف عن مصير الفتاه الى حد
الان
[موسيقى]
تداول الانشطه على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي مقطع فيديو طريف لديكن يقتحم
مجلس رجال في احدى المناسبات واظهر المقطع
الاطفال وهم يلاحقون الديك داخل المجلس
ويحاولون الامساك به فيما يعلو سياحه
الشهير في المكان
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ضجه مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي بمقطع فيديو
عن رصد السلطات الامريكيه لمخلوق فضائي
قيل انه هبط في صحن طائر وقد رصدته كاميرا
مراقبه خاصه باحدى العائلات وسط سخريه
عارمه من القصه على مواقع التواصل وفي وقت
سابق قال البيت الابيض انه لا يوجد اي
مؤشر على وجود كائنات فضائيه او نشاط
خارجي كوكب الارض
[موسيقى]
خلال جنازتها استفاقت وعادت للحياه في
حادثه اثارت ذهولا في الاكوادور امراه
تتنفس فجاه من داخل نعش كانت كان كان بحسب
ما روى ابن السيده حادثه السيده حادثه
وصفتها وسائل اعلام عالميه بانها العائده
من الموت ويظهر الفيديو السيده البالغه من
العمر 76 عاما محاطه برجلين اتيان
لمساعدتها السيده الان موضوعه تحت اجهزه
التنفس الاصطناعي وقلبها مستقر
[موسيقى]
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات